c'est la nuit dernière après quinze
jours de procès que le terroriste carlos
a finalement été condamné à la prison à
perpétuité pour le triple meurtre de la
rue toullier en 1975 à paris après ses
défenseurs carlos en personne s'est
lancé dans une invraisemblable
plaidoirie de plus de quatre heures mais
qui finalement n'a pas influencer les
jurés agnès vahramian bruno livertout il
est armé il esquisse un sourire ce
verdict les fils des victimes
l'attendait depuis 22 ans apaisé ils ne
sont pour autant pas satisfait j'aurais
quand même aimé entendre j'ai tué votre
père et pour telle raison ça je n'ai pas
entendu
j'espère que carlo cela dit il y aura
une suite à ce procès j'espère qu'un
jour je l'entendais il tourne autour du
pot il veut pas aborder les faits
et il assume pas ce qu'il a fait ce
qu'il a un peu il a honte de ce qu'il a
fait par rapport à ces idéologies
pendant ce procès carlos n'a pas nier
n'a pas avoué non plus ses crimes il n'a
simplement pas voulu coopérer avec cette
justice qui l'a condamné dit-il par
avance c'est un combattant communiste
que l'on a voulu condamner et c'est à ce
titre là qu'il peut être qu'il peut
considérer que cette condamnation
confirme le caractère exclusivement
politique de cette procédure pour autant
les avocats de carlos commis d'office
ont soulevé des incohérences des manques
comme l'absence des témoins à la barre
c'est un peu dommage que le procès
carlos étaient expédiées en huit jours
au pas de charge par la cour d'assises
de paris parce que je crois qu'on a
montré qu'ils posaient beaucoup de
questions
c'était la première condamnation de
carlos qui est mis en examen dans quatre
dossiers de terrorisme encore à
l'instruction après le verdict le rideau
est tombé la représentation de carlos et
que terminer la salle s'est vidée le
jury est parti une autre audience a
commencé si venue celle là sans enjeu et
nous avons assisté à un moment de vérité
un avocat de la partie civile s'est
approché de carlos tout près pour lui
demander mais pourquoi ne pas avoir
avoué les crimes de la rue toullier
carlos a alors répondu parce que ce
n'était pas une manière de faire le
procès puis il a insisté la rue toullier
n'était pas un attentat c'était une
arrestation avons-nous compris à
laquelle il s'agit de résister plus tard
l'osce a quitté le box en souriant sur
ce qui ressemblait un demi aveu